et notre invité c'est le cinéaste et
producteur Robert guediguian bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
c'est un plaisir on a beaucoup de sujets
on a envie d'avoir votre regard sur
beaucoup de sujets notamment sur le
cinéma aujourd'hui sur la politique sur
la gauche notamment et on va évidemment
commencer par l'Arménie puisque vous
êtes d'origine arménienne et depuis un
mois et demi l'Azerbaïdjan a lancé une
offensive contre l'Arménie dans une
forme d'indifférence de la communauté
internationale est-ce que vous le
regrettez oui je le regrette mais je je
le comprends et ça s'explique de manière
assez simple c'est à dire que
l'arméniste une confettis en fait c'est
un tout petit pays qui n'a pas de
ressources et qui présente très peu
d'intérêt en fait donc économique et de
sur une vue et c'est il passe pour
quantité négligeable en fait c'est un
peu
par rapport
surtout pas de concurrence victimaire je
veux dire comment donc évidemment je ce
qui se passe en Ukraine c'est pas ça
mais on ne peut pas négliger
effectivement un pays de d'intervenir
dans un pays sous prétexte qu'il n'a pas
de ressources et qu'il vient dire qu'il
n'a pas d'intérêt à tous les sens du
terme pour vous c'est ça c'est ça qui
explique le fait cette forme
d'indifférence c'est que la communauté
internationale a une réagit en fonction
de ses intérêts c'est une évidence
géopolitique depuis la nuit des temps je
n'ai peur je veux dire je crois j'ai
peur que ça ne change pas dans le temps
qui viennent donc notre boulot à nous si
vous êtes un intervenir contre ce
géopolitique essayer de la essayer entre
guillemets je veux dire d'intervenir sur
des principes sur des valeurs sur de la
morale on peut pas à la fois défendre
certains principes comme le fait là où
le dit en tout cas la Commission
européenne et puis aller signer un
accord avec l'Azerbaïdjan sur le gaz ça
c'est quelque chose qui nous arménien
mais qui nous citoyen devrait nous
Jules serré parce que bon évidemment
laservation est une dictature elle
fournit d'ailleurs 25% de son de son gaz
et et retourne en actionnariat je veux
dire à la Russie donc c'est absolument
Andy en fait tu dis quand je vois la
photo de
lièvre mais dans la main et tout sourire
je
j'ai un haut le coeur ça me dit de
provocation vous voyez voilà est-ce que
vous dites que l'Union européenne doit
arrêter d'acheter du gaz à laser
c'est en contradiction avec ses valeurs
mais bien sûr on peut le faire
je dirais si vous voulez dans un monde
idéal les politiques pour expliquer
effectivement à leur population que
effectivement il ne peut pas soutenir de
tels dictatures à les finançants donc en
achetant leurs produits et que du coup
peut-être faudra-t-il sur un stream
encore un peu plus ça me fait voilà je
je moi si on me dit qu'il faut baisser
bon chauffage d'un degré de plus pour ne
pas donner de l'argent à une dictature
en sanglante je veux bien baisser mon
chauffage voilà c'est très d'explication
de pédagogique que les politiques
devraient faire plutôt que de d'être
comme plaisant avec leur opinion
publique c'est pas comme plaisant c'est
de pas leur dire en fait c'est avoir
peur de leur dire parce qu'on a peur de
ne pas être réélu quoi parce
qu'évidemment il y a des pressions
partout des électorats le peuple est
composé de tas de fractions différentes
bien sûr on le sait tous qu'est-ce que
vous attendez aujourd'hui de la France
qu'est-ce que vous attendez du
gouvernement sur cette question de
l'Arménie
d'abord une reconnaissance
ferme et définitive de l'Arménie et et
une discussion qui redémarre sur le
haut-karaba le karaba est un statut
différent de l'armée du local toujours
pas été reconnu par la communauté
internationale donc cette discussion là
se termine ça fait 25 ans qu'elle est
dur et ça n'a pas bougé et que pour ce
qui concerne l'Arménie si on veut agir
comme on agit en Ukraine c'est-à-dire
dans le respect des frontières léguées
par l'Union soviétique dire que ce qui
se passe en Azerbaïdjan et en Arménie
exactement la même chose que ce qui se
passe à l'Ukraine et en Russie
c'est-à-dire que la Russie ne reconnaît
pas les anciennes frontières
ne reconnaît pas les frontières de
l'Union soviétique du coup là je vois
pas très bien comment on fait si ce
n'est un ayant des mesures très lourdes
je veux dire genre force d'interposition
pourquoi pas des casques bleus en
Arménie qui impasse qui empêchent des
azéries de de de rentrer dans le
territoire ce qu'ils ont fait il y a
quelques semaines je veux dire et à ce
moment-là il y a quand même des pauvres
villageois qui n'en met pas de
chaussettes pas de vêtements etc qui
avait un fusil de chasse quasiment
essaie de protéger la frontière bon
puisqu'il était inégalité n'oublions pas
donc je le redis que l'Arménie est un
pays mais absolument absolument pauvre
très pauvre qui n'a aucune ressource
naturelle si ce n'est justement j'allais
dire c'est pas une ressource naturelle
pour se lier à une tragédie qui si ce
n'est cette diaspora voilà et ça veut
dire c'est quoi le rôle de cette
diaspard comment vous aujourd'hui
français d'origine arménienne vous vivez
ce conflit de là où vous êtes nous de
manière très claire en fait je pense que
si on parle aujourd'hui de l'Arménie
peut-être que si je suis là aujourd'hui
c'est parce qu'effectivement c'est
mobilisé donc je crois que les diaspora
2 à 2 missions très très importantes
d'une part effectivement par tous les
moyens possibles et imaginables parler
de ce conflit donc pour rappeler des
principes et en parlant de ce conflit
c'est parler de tous les petits conflits
dans le monde non je dis vous venez de
parler des yésidi voilà les plus
les plus encouragés en ce moment bon
donc c'est très bien
donc la diaspora de communiquer maximum
d'une part et doit je le dis vraiment je
le dis brutalement doit payer quoi c'est
à dire il faut que nous versions nous
sommes à l'initiative avec askento Rania
et ciment cardiaque
nous sommes à l'initiative d'une sorte
de prélèvement volonté mais moi je veux
bien voilà je veux même bien appeler ça
un impôt voilà je crois que les
Arméniens dans le monde ne peuvent plus
se contenter de dire oui je suis
arménien j'ai quelques notions de langue
arménienne et
à la mobilisation vous dites aux
Arméniens de la diaspora certif alerté
acteur
il faut verser de l'argent tous les mois
à l'Arménie parce qu'ils ont trop pauvre
pour survivre et au-delà de la diaspora
est-ce que vous dites aussi aux Français
qui ne sont pas d'origine arménienne il
faut s'intéresser à ce conflit bien sûr
mais de nombreux Français s'y
intéressent vous savez moi la pétition
que j'ai lancé plusieurs à propos
justement de cette collecte quand on
appelle l'Arménie tous les mois
puisqu'il s'agirait de faire un
prélèvement mensuel tous les mois au
minimum de 10 euros d'ailleurs c'est pas
une fortune c'est ceux qui peuvent
donner plus ce n'est bien venu mais 10
euros ce qui a un pas une tuerie
j'ai demandé des soutiers moi je veux
dire les frères darder elles vont
soutenir régulièrement soutenu Annie
Arnaud prix Nobel maintenant soutenu
Laurent Binet je dois l'oublier Bontempi
qui ne se vexe pas mais
ça doit dépasser ce milieu c'est aussi
votre appel aujourd'hui
très très connues et qui ne sont pas
d'origine arménienne mais qui
soutiennent le principe même de la
nécessité j'allais dire de la diversité
culturelle pour je pourrais vous savez
que j'ai fait j'ai fait un papier qui
disait que l'espèce arménienne était
menacée de disparition pour bien
insister sur cette idée de c'est ça qui
risque d'arriver parce que si mais si
l'Arménie était dévorée par
l'Azerbaïdjan je crois que la manière
dont la culture arménienne existe encore
un diaspora disparaîtrait aussi tu as
plus ou moins long terme parce que je
crois pas qu'il existe effectivement le
diaspora c'est un point d'ancrage en
fait voilà un mot sur le rôle des
politiques puisque le 15 novembre
prochain c'est-à-dire dans 10 jours au
Sénat sera examiné un projet de
résolution à l'initiative de Bruno
retaille auquel président du groupe les
républicains qui demandent des sanctions
à l'encontre de l'Azerbaïdjan et qui
exige le retrait immédiat du territoire
arménien est-ce que les parlementaires
français elle a aussi ont un rôle à
jouer sur cette question
je crois parce que je crois que le
combat il se passe il doit se passer
partout il doit se passer dans les
médias les prises de parole etc des uns
et des ordres tous les Arméniens le font
grosso modo mais il doit se masser aussi
du point de vue comme ça de
l'institutionnel on va c'est à dire de
toutes les institutions publiques mais
les régions les villages les villes
évidemment les parlementaires donc il
faut
c'est ce que on a fait on a dressé le le
drapeau arménien sur la mairie de
Marseille par exemple il y a quelques
tailles deux semaines je crois
c'était je remercie d'ailleurs la
municipalité d'avoir accepté tout de
suite et très volontiers de le faire
de s'engager à le faire et évidemment on
a appelé ce jour-là toutes les mairies
qui le souhaitent et j'ai appelé tous
les Arméniens qui étaient où qu'il soit
insisté auprès de leurs élus pour qu'il
vienne avoir mener sur un maximum de
Myriam France tout ça beaucoup de retour
oui oui il y en a pas mal de parisienne
etc je sais et puis on a des petits
villages parfois donc évidemment
l'importance des élus locaux des
parlementaires un dernier mot là-dessus
puisque lundi les deux parties étaient
réunis à Sotchi en Russie autour de
Vladimir Poutine est-ce que ce sommet il
a soulevé chez vous l'espoir d'un
règlement du conflit
on va dire toute prise de parole toute
parole et préférable aux armes voilà
donc je vis bien sûr que oui voilà
pas tout seul et pas à ce moment on va
dire en plus parce que effectivement
l'harmonie bizarrement était vassaliser
longtemps je dis en sortant de l'Union
soviétique sa seule protection a été la
nouvelle Russie voilà bon et depuis
qu'elle a ses démocratisé bizarrement ou
pas bizarrement plutôt
elle a été un peu lâchée on va dire par
la Russie donc elle se retrouve très
seule aujourd'hui c'est pour ça qu'il
faut pas se remettre sous le sous la la
tutelle de la Russie je veux dire il
faut il faut être protégé par la
communauté internationale bon après si
la Russie fait quelque chose à un moment
donné on prononce qu'on nous donne je
veux dire pour je vous dis je vous dis
c'est une question de survie donc on
peut pas
jouer pour vous dans ce conflit où il y
a une forme d'impuissance
à la politique internationale donc il a
le il représente la France dans l'Europe
la France dans le monde évidemment il a
un rôle à jouer ni plus ni moins il a le
rôle de la France a joué
là je je
pense que c'est un peu avancé là dans le
mois que qui vient de s'écouler mais je
bois là parce que j'ai toujours envie
d'être de l'optimisme mais je suis un
optimisme un peu désespéré c'est à dire
que si je puis dire on peut utiliser un
maximum mais c'est vrai que
j'étais tellement de doute en fait sur
sur des pays où déjà d'ailleurs pas des
peuples bien sûr mais déjà comme un lief
ou comme
Erdogan bien sûr qui partent parenthèse
je veux dire le commandement militaire
de l'Azerbaïdjan de l'armée
d'azerbaïdiale pour le savoir c'est des
généreux Turcs voilà et les Turcs qui
ont toujours ce vieux rêve de
fou qui n'y est plus beaucoup
d'Arméniens dans le monde
voici donc je suis ravi qu'ils sont un
code et qu'il parle mais j'ai toujours
peur donc je voudrais vraiment des
garanties partout quoi je dis voilà il y
aurait des casques bleus à la frontière
de l'Arménie aujourd'hui je préférerais
ça à
cet appel à la mobilisation que vous
lancez mobilisation de la diaspora
mobilisation des français et même
au-delà bien sûr
on se fera dans le monde entier bien sûr
parce qu'on passe par la forêt de France
mais le formulaire de France est une on
pourrait dire un ex du fort mini mondial
donc il y a des forêts partout au Canada
là par exemple une action conjointe avec
le forum meunier de Hollande donc le
dispositif comme ça de récolte d'argent
dans toute la diaspora du monde en fait
doit se faire à travers le foraminé on
va parler puisque vous êtes un artiste
engagé envers engagé à gauche vous ne
vous en cachez pas il y a tout juste un
an vous publiez les longueurs en
tronciles encore à l'époque vous étiez
inquiet la disparition de la gauche en
France est-ce que c'est toujours le cas
est apparu parce que j'ai aussi j'aurais
pu si j'avais pas fait si demain
j'aurais peut-être été historique mais
donc on a toujours des surprises à
l'histoire
jamais voilà donc personne ne pouvait
prévoir effectivement au moment où
j'écrivais ce livre que
et où l'union autour de la
présidentielle ne se faisait pas que
l'Union se ferait 15 jours plus tard
autour de législatives mais ça c'est
fait voilà parce que c'est comme ça
c'est des choses pour vous la nuque
c'est le retour de la gauche
il faut absolument bien sûr ce battre
moi j'y mettrais toutes mes forces pour
que la nuque continue à exister c'est
si vous voulez y aller comme toujours
les efforts qui qui souhaitent sa
disparition en particulier les vieux du
Parti socialiste j'allais dire
isole-le-folan a fait tous ces vieux
qui ne veulent absolument pas par de
leur retraite je dirais alors que
effectivement socialistes qui ont 35 ans
40 ans qui d'ailleurs reprennent les
valeurs du Parti socialiste des
fondateurs de l'histoire du Parti
socialiste donc des années 30 du Front
populaire pour vous la nuque n'a pas
effacé le Parti socialiste parce que je
suis une partie des spécialiste
c'est la renaissance du Parti socialiste
fort en ce moment un discours que j'ai
toujours rêvé d'entendre chez les
socialistes qui le disque et le discours
qui ressemble je dis au discours de de
la Fondation même au discours où les
communistes et les socialistes et c'est
pas été passés par eux et quoi je veux
dire je veux dire c'est bon j'ai
toujours passé qu'il fallait refaire le
congrès de tour à l'envers donc il faut
faire une fédération en fait des gauches
et je te fais des rations des gauches et
n'existe là il y a aussi des écologistes
vous le savez
à François Hollande par exemple puisque
vous l'avez cité de se retirer d'arrêter
de parler il fait du temps à la gauche
pour vous
je suis vraiment très très fâché oui un
peu quand on a quand on a grosso modo je
veux dire je pense que l'histoire le
dira quand on a mis la dernière appelé
sur le cadavre du Parti socialiste
mais effectivement
toutes ces promesses par rapport à la
finance et tout il a fait le virage
libéral de fou de folie
et du coup qu'aujourd'hui il vient
encore pérorer sur sur la nuque par
exemple sur l'union de la gauche qu'il
aurait dû faire lui ou d'autres
d'ailleurs même avant lui me
[Musique]
me déplaît mais fortement fortement
fortement vous êtes plutôt pareil pour
le folle
avec eux mais pas beaucoup vous êtes
chauds
le plus
étymologique du terme philosophique en
fait oui oui je suis communiste être
communiste il suffit pas trop Parti
communiste si vous voulez rien à voir
avec le Parti communiste chinois si poux
Hollande mais bon tu as bien Roussel il
n'est pas tendre non plus avec la nuque
on l'a vu par exemple cette semaine il a
pas voté la motion
Parti communiste là voilà
je trouve même que beaucoup de
communistes doivent se retourner dans
leur tombe quand je le vois
manifester avec la police dire faire ces
espèces de blagues en fait c'est des
blagues sur le bifteck sur le ou sur le
coup de rouge tout ça évidemment la
dernière sortie si je puis dire la
dernière saillie sur le travail
bon c'est des c'est parti communiste
c'est le parti communiste de Twitter
quoi je veux dire c'est pas du il y a
aucun point de vente théorique est-ce
qu'il dit enfin je trouve ça terrible
terrible terrible aussi pas du tout je
le mets avec François Hollande il
faudrait que ça n'aille
le débat politique actuel quand vous
voyez par exemple ce qui s'est passé
hier à l'Assemblée nationale
ça aussi
[Musique]
mais j'ai dit que j'étais optimiste
aussi mais non non
regardez cette phase par exemple fou
qu'on discute sur est-ce qu'il y avait
un S ou pas à qui retourne bon mais même
s'il n'y a qui est un ou pas d'ailleurs
la phrase de toute façon elle est
raciste même si elle ne s'adresse pas
directement à ce député d'origine
africaine qui est né en France bon
monsieur
raciste on ne dit pas une phrase de ce
type là qu'il retourne en Afrique
à la limite on pourrait dire qu'il
retourne dans leur pays d'origine ce que
je conteste aussi mais là mais qu'il
retourne en Afrique est une phrase
raciste avec ou sans s et qu'elle soit
adressée à quelqu'un
de qui est loin on voit quelqu'un qui
est un peu importe donc je vois pas de
quoi on parle oui c'est une phrase
raciste et le racisme n'a pas le droit
de de citer dans l'Assemblée nationale
voilà il doit sélectionner pour aller
donc je sais pas de quoi on parle je
comprends pas je sais pas ce que disent
les gens je les comprends pas
parle du rassemblement national on a
constaté une poussée du rassemblement
national on le voit il y a 89 députés
notamment du côté de chez vous dans le
sud de la France et dans les zones
rurales comment vous l'expliquez ça
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est le
rassemblement national ou est-ce que
c'est parce que la gauche n'est plus en
mesure de répondre aux aspirations de
ces classes populaires
à diminué c'est des endroits la gauche
c'est renforcée on peut expliquer le
rassemblement national que par
l'affaiblissement de la gauche depuis 30
ans et par la politique effectivement de
certains socialistes depuis 30 ans dont
François Hollande voilà le contribué ce
que
tu vois politique qui était exactement
la même que la droite donc on ne peut
pas face à ça quand on a des difficultés
on cherche un recours s'il n'y a pas la
gauche il savait que pendant un certain
temps il n'y avait pas la gauche il y
avait le rassemblement national
heureusement quoi qu'on pense il y a un
type qui s'appelle un Mélenchon qui a
créé les insoumis il rester bien
l'histoire comme quelqu'un qui a
reconstitué un grand mouvement de gauche
les insoumis étant d'ailleurs j'allais
dire sociologiquement est un peu près ce
qui était le Parti communiste au fond
dans les années 70 où moi j'ai
adoréistes
on peut pas on peut pas
bouger la politique de ce type là et on
peut même pas juger les hommes que celui
qui n'a jamais péché mais jette la
première pierre comme disait l'Évangile
et pour revenir au rassemblement
national et à cette poussée qu'est-ce
que vous leur dites ce matin à ces
électeurs qui votent rassemblement
national parce que pour eux le
rassemblement national apporte une
réponse un problème qu'il mesure deux
choses que l'on va simplement nationale
d'ailleurs était continué à être du
bonheur économique du côté effectivement
des riches
augmentation du SPIC etc les choses
comme ça donc
[Musique]
si on regarde attentivement
effectivement le problème du Front
national c'est un programme de droite du
rassemblement
ne pas oublier que nationale vient du
Front national quand même ne pas oublier
ça parce que là
ce qui s'est passé hier qui doit
évidemment énormément gêné les stratège
du rassemblement national et en
particulier Marine Le Pen montre bien
qu'effectivement le faux le faux raciste
du Front national est toujours quand
même bien présent sous le sous le
rassemblement national donc si vous
n'êtes pas raciste et si vous voulez si
vous êtes du côté des pauvres gens aller
chercher plutôt du côté de cette
nouvelle gauche et qui vient
d'apparaître et essayer de renforcer
parce que c'est là qui va travailler
pour vous la dédiabolisations du
rassemblement national c'est un vernis
ah bah oui je crois oui je crois un
dernier mot sur le cinéma le cinéma
français comment il se porte aujourd'hui
le cinéma français pour vous
la diversité de grande diversité du
cinéma français existe toujours mais je
vais aller menacer voilà elle a toujours
été beaucoup plus aujourd'hui d'abord
parce que
on est toujours en train de 35 % de
moins qu'en 19 avant le covid et là je
vous expliquais comment juste parce que
allez-y non si vous avez une explication
après je voudrais vous parler du coup
c'était quelque chose de je croise c'est
à dire je pense qu'il y a quelque chose
là il y a des gens qui ont perdu une
habitude ça va très vite on avait vu
avec la télé en Italie par exemple bon
dans les années 80 c'est vrai qu'il y a
des gens qui pendant deux ans ne sont
pas allés au cinéma voilà ils ont perdu
l'habitude d'y aller voilà ils ont perdu
le chemin ça va plus comment faire et
que là c'est plus l'adresse
je veux dire une chose très
qui peut sembler comme une provocation
mais je il faut baisser les prix c'est
trop cher
des abonnements tout ça je m'en fous de
tout ça d'abord il n'a pas partout non
il faut baisser global le prix de du
cinéma mais pour baisser le prix du
cinéma donc en général de manière
absolument générale à étudier que au cas
par cas bien sûr selon les régions selon
les villes selon les abonnements etc si
on baisse le prix ça veut dire que les
producteurs de je fais partie les
distributeurs les exploitants
et les riches salariés du cinéma il y en
a donc les acteurs riches les
techniciens ceux qui travaillent
beaucoup je parle pas des pauvres
intermittents qui qui est mal fou
doivent aussi renoncer un petit peu à
leur salaire parce que j'avais je vous
garantis que des des ils sont
exorbitants voilà
il faut se remettre en question oui pour
l'instant les producteurs les
distributeurs et les
exploitants et les acteurs qui
travaillent beaucoup et les techniciens
travaillent beaucoup gagnent beaucoup
d'argent voilà je dis voilà c'est pour
ça que je dis c'est un peu le
provocation mais
il faut accepter de gagner moins parce
que sinon les Français ne viendront plus
au cinéma
la place le prix des places diminue de
manière conséquente d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui ça peut attendre 15 euros
je sais pas quelque chose comme ça
peut-être
donc c'est au milieu du cinéma de se
remettre en question
un dernier mot puisque évidemment il y a
une ville votre ville de coeur la ville
qui vous inspire c'est Marseille et vous
inspire toujours autant cette ville de
Marseille après toutes ces années
oui c'est à dire je dis que c'est je dis
souvent que
si tu nous forme une formule mais je dis
que c'est mon langage en fait c'est à
dire une c'est une forme pour moi
Marseille aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
j'écris des films avec avec la mer
Méditerranée
avec des platanes avec des toits de
tuiles avec ce qui fait la ce qu'on voit
en images quand on tourne à Marseille
voilà ces éléments de langage là de
décors de décors naturels de bon de
corps et de décor on va dire etc
monsieur sont nécessaires mais bon je
fais je fais très de manière très
volontariste des expériences très
lointaines de temps en temps pour
effectivement mieux revenir à Marseille
donc je vais faire un tour à Bamako je
vais faire un tour en Arménie je vais
faire une tour même avec le promeneur du
Champ de Mars je vais faire un tour dans
le nord de la France ou à Paris et pour
revenir à Marseille plus ressourcée et
pour retravailler là c'est la plus belle
ville du monde pour vous
j'allais dire j'allais dire bien sûr que
non mais bien sûr que oui
il est presque fini j'ai tourné déjà
j'ai tourné alors à Marseille
effectivement j'ai tourné à partir des
efforts de domaine de la rue d'Aubagne
je dis bien à partir c'est pas un film
sur les effondrement de la rue d'Aubagne
mais ce trajet dit où il y a eu 8 morts
donc
et le point de départ et un peu le
centre de film qui parle de toutes les
manières de s'engager aujourd'hui je
veux dire donc non seulement de la
manière politique et Monsieur de manière
humanitaire d'une manière à
l'internationale d'une manière
médicale de manière associative
comme ça je tisse un peu tous les liens
de l'engagement sous le regard de la
statue d'Homère
je pense après ça dépend de ce qui est
un festival est-ce qu'il y a pas de
festival donc la stratégie peut au plus
tôt ou plutôt en mars
au plus tôt on espère nous en parler
merci infiniment
et de nous avoir éclairé de votre regard
sur cette actualité merci Robert
[Musique]